the really believe he's a vegan Pollux
to a shape believe he's a vegan but I
know why he stipulates and says he's a
vegan so [ __ ] being a vegan I like meat
so you know means I like steak I love
chicken right now we're in South Beach
Miami on a training camp in preparation
for my March full annihilation of one
Tony the bellend belly is sipping a
protein shake from a [ __ ] cocktail
glass
um jookin and out in the gym in the
freezing cold [ __ ] sheffield beaches
are lovely I went to be today Crosby
Medina it was freezing cold there's dog
tried to piss on me like not quite Miami
but you know it was Crosby meaning
liberal I enjoyed it I've decided to
base myself here and in Miami for a few
reasons
first off London at the moment is pretty
cold and miserable I wanted this
training camp to be a happy vibe I
wanted to wake up in the morning I
wanted to go to the beach I wanted to
swim I wanted to relax I went to
meditate ones do all of the things that
I find it difficult to do in London it's
just to get away from me maybe living
londonium just [ __ ] miles away from
me living healthy eating clean you know
getting some Sun in your face being in a
nice healthy environment for me makes a
massive difference I get more out of
myself he is not prepared for that dog
fight I am prepared to every possible
fight he brings to the table I'm not
gonna do a different song than that Tony
belly isn't designed for fighting he
doesn't have what a real fighter needs
it doesn't have the physical attributes
doesn't have the speed doesn't have the
agility he doesn't have the technical
know-how doesn't have the toughness I've
got something inside of there that he
could never ever much
and I can just keep going don't ask me I
would do it all why I don't know I must
be the [ __ ] fat Energizer Bunny guys
poor little guys his whole life caught
guys away twelve and a half stone it's
not rocket science here with the enemy
that it's the weight of one go to
another day
naturally the later guy's going to be
the faster one when I think of Tony
belly and how he's probably preparing
you know long jogs you know maybe
Sprint's in a freezing cold Park no
woody hat on freezing and every time I
do think that I smiled to myself because
no matter all that pain he's putting
himself through he's irrelevant because
as soon as I connect onto his chin he's
going to sleep for a long time do you
think I'm gonna give you two answers to
that question yes I think he will but
you know what I'm gonna save him because
I'm gonna give them a very much because
I'm nice like that
[Music]